Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a very fair question about
electric vehicles.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, I just have a question
about electric cars, I'm all for it.
The only thing is that electricity still is
produced with coal and natural gas and fossil
fuels.
So how is it that?
It's going to save anything because I feel
like what we're doing is removing the fuel
from the actual car just to a power plant
in someone's neighborhood.
Hopefully there's a better answer there is.
Speaker 1: So here's the deal.
First of all, it is not true that all electricity
comes from fossil fuels, but most electricity
still does come from fossil fuels, although
it is diminishing in the United States.
I've spoken to energy activists and technologists
about this exact issue.
You plug in the electric car great, the car
drives around and there's no emissions, but
that electricity came from fossil fuels.
First of all, you can power electric vehicles
with renewably sourced electricity.
I have solar panels and then I've got the
electric car, so it's coming from the Sun
now.
The solar panels have some of a carbon footprint.
That's true.
They were manufactured and they were shipped,
but it is lower.
But you can power electric vehicles with renewables.
You can generate electricity with solar and
wind.
You've also got nonrenewable but more efficient
geothermal new, safe nuclear.
I'm not a new, pro-nuclear activist, but I
recognize that if we built new nuclear now,
it would not be like what there was 50 years
ago.
OK, fine.
We don't even need to get into it.
Most of the electricity is not coming from
renewables, but you can get electricity from
renewable.
So if you're driving around in a gas powered
car, you're burning fuel.
And as more electricity comes from renewables,
you're still driving around in a gas powered
car.
There's no way to make the gas powered car
renewable if you have the electric car as
electricity transitions away from fossil fuels.
More and more vehicle miles are being powered
by renewable energy.
OK, that's number one.
Second, even if electricity is coming from
say, you know, I don't know, some kind of
fossil fuel.
If the fossil fuel is all being burned in
one place rather than coming out of a million
vehicle tailpipes, you still have a better
chance at figuring out how to capture the
emissions from those fossil fuels, all at
the power plant, rather than having to figure
out what to do with a million different tailpipes
that are driving around.
So you're kind of just pushing up the energy
ladder.
You're obviously completely right that right
now, most electricity still does come from
fossil fuels, but it doesn't have to.
And more importantly, that's going to transition
over time.
That's the answer.
You know, we've interviewed energy experts
on this and I've spoken to them personally,
and that's essentially the way it works.
And the transition that we need to keep pushing
is for more and more electricity.
And this is, by the way, the same reason that
if you have an electric oven.
Once the electricity comes from a renewable,
you've close the loop if you have a gas oven,
no matter what, you're burning fossil fuels.
And that's a lot of the reason why one of
the big moves right now in renewable energy
is let's start retrofitting an entire go building
by building.
You put solar panels on the roof, you put
in an electric heat pump mini split type system
for heating.
You put in an electric oven.
It's now and you put in a car charger and
then you, you plug in your car.
You've now gone from the roof to the garage,
so to speak on electric, and it can come from
renewable energy.
So that's why there's so much focus on that
right now.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
New York, as the pandemic wanes, wants to
get people riding the subway again.
One of the reasons a lot of people aren't
going back to the New York subways is because
there are lots of people living in the subways,
and there are more incidents of sucker punches
and people being pushed in front of trains
that are being reported on.
I don't know if it's happening more, but it's
being reported on it more.
And New York City wants to deal with that,
but how are they going to deal with that?
Is it going to be oppressive?
We're going to talk about that.
Number two, Democrats have again introduced
a bill to eliminate these tax subsidies when
sports teams build new stadiums.
Maybe will it pass this time?
We will discuss, and we have a new study that
claims that when there are stand your ground
laws enacted, homicides go up 11 percent,
not justifiable uses of guns for self-defense.
Legal homicides illegal homicides go up 11
percent.
We're going to talk about that on the bonus
show.
All of those stories and more are at your
fingertips.
When you sign up at Join Pacman dot com, you
can use the code Woud 22 on our website to
get a discount.
Unidentified: We will speak to you that.